Marcus Phoenix morirá en Gears of War 6
mucho se ha hablado sobre la nueva
trilogía de Gears y el rumbo argumental
que está tomando y Aunque al principio
parecía que era una trilogía más
amigable luego nos dimos cuenta de que
le sigue importando un si tienen
que matar a medio mundo para seguir con
la trama esta vez el personaje que tiene
a todos preocupados es el mismísimo
Marcus Y es que siendo honestos es muy
común que en este tipo de secuelas uno
de los personajes principales muera y
más aún si hablamos de Gears of War the
coalition no ha revelado ni un solo
detalle pero que no se ha aguantado las
ganas es cliff blinski quien hace poco
comentó que si la saga siguiera sus
manos Él no dudaría en matar a Marcus en
el siguiente juego muchos creen que para
que la trama pueda evolucionar la saga
debe dejar atrás el pasado y acabar con
Marcus pero habrá que esperar prefieres
que Marcus viva o que le den una gran
despedida